hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Bobby go ahead
whatever with the thing that I got to do
this because it's important
the fans needs know we're here for a
reason push me out of the way just get
into the surgery we're here to play
surgeon simulator because on the ps4 it
came
are you moving my arm please thank you
very much no we're here because we need
to do this surgery and what was they
even saying I totally screw that up
because you must be up I'm gonna start
over hello everybody my name is
markiplier and I'm here with Bob and
Wade's in the background back there but
because this is a two-player game with
surgeon simulator on the 2.10 Ferrari we
don't for its backwards I don't know why
can't I hear anything anymore
oh god dammit I've never actually played
this game you know there we go
you know what mark what what that's hard
to do that's yeah how do you like oh all
up in your face it's a really fun if you
couldn't tell the motion controls with
the ps4 is this ridiculous so they
intentionally made it that way because
they saw okay buddy we're professionals
yeah let's uh let's go to Chester I've
also ha you control the camera Allah
yeah I mean I need the this okay you can
see that Paul how do I go down anymore
oh you just hold it yeah well out of
that let's do this together
just turn it turn it yeah I let go I'll
be back
alternate and you guided around sort of
right in there just rake it across the
ribs just play like a bad phone no
you're not in my world I think my
professional opinion so well I'm here to
do some work I don't know just the most
amazing doctor I've heard stories about
odo why do I blow them all God oh I was
just scooping out the liver oh that's
for later that one for later
how about for now let me see if you'd
make mark I'm trying to help doctor is
this supposed to be whoa oh wait yeah
that might that might work yeah I have
an idea idea okay go for it that's good
good that's gonna that's gonna do it
you can stop getting on top of me I'm
trying to get on about why I finally the
right hand is the dominant hand
apparently that's just it's the top the
right hand is tops come on grab your
hand all right
maybe wait wait wait what shooting you
know
got this delicate rib right here in this
long and now it's like facing through it
you know whatever that's probably the
disease - yeah yeah whoa how are you so
much better with a softener because I
don't care about the patients will be I
don't really care about the patient
suave black hair less oh you were
killing him yeah well you know it moving
like this that's like absolutely nothing
shut up I wanted to do it because it
felt good so if I remember from what you
did last time you get it sort of yeah I
get around there right just oh whoa now
drop it in there okay
it's gonna do its job that's an
automated saw so only fans
it's pretty nice it's a fancy surf you
true technology because I'm wait wait
wait wait we should should make sure
that the patient survives this would you
come the hill over here a little bit I'm
watching Marc come here you can't just
our time come Aussie the second I leave
he dies he died fast your input is not
required Wade you're not a part of this
let play I'm your I'm your nurse you're
my nurse I'm your nurse so nurse Jean on
a perform the surgery
no sorry doc yeah you know how much I
love those cigarettes oh sorry yeah you
know it's funny that you're my nurse and
we're separate people but it kind of
seems like what we're two arms on the
same no I know I've never felt this
close to you before what do you want
with you um wait can we clap I hope so I
always wanted to do this yeah you broke
I'm sorry I'll buy you to do with the
nernst all right well that's random hi
do you do this doc yeah no I don't think
so
this book is stuck on the table just
give me a sec all right I'll be over
here duel good I had a late night
all best with Chase who goochy goochy
goochy goochy goochy hammer just get in
my hand
Oh gotta be really angry you do that
I'll break out of this school
come over here absorbs it drill I come
over here nurse yes doc come over and
stop stop murdering the face what oh go
that way
[Music]
just just know you need a drill no does
he need it a no okay no does you need to
bring the back to me first my voice no
kid Mara fine help me hammer the [ __ ]
out of this ribs
oh there's only one hammer just know if
I put my hand in front of it will it
dispersal of the force okay
[Music]
hey the rib phasing technique finally
paid a welcome doctor both lungs have
been properly removed this whole rib
smashing things go a lot smoother now
good
nothing says Briggs smashing like
teleporting lungs excuse me excuse me
Danny
I really looking forward to the end of
the video I have a very sturdy voice oh
yes abusing my throat if you know what I
mean I don't would you elaborate I will
you see never mind
oh well that's no fun you wanna go there
dog yeah alright well you know how it's
okay
my [ __ ]
exploits here we go they used to let
women into the army if they had a beard
so I went in knowing that the only way
I'd survive is to infiltrate the
Vietcong via their dicks so I went into
their tunnel oh you went into their dog
into their tunnels and when they're down
there it's just a big orgy just a big
pile of them that's how they make so man
a and then was that racist long story
short I suck their dicks I was exactly
what I was hoping
okay I don't know you wanna you wanna
cry trip with me nurse is it green you
got to go down it's green is it green it
is yeah look gimme
it's the Creator give give it to me
doctor you know I'm probably gonna bleep
[Music]
I just throw the cute suits into the
pocket oh those you just do that because
I'm good at what I do
ha I'm gonna make my hand time how the
hell did you just do that well as you
can see when you have skills such as me
it works out whoa look at your hand
bro he'd be bleeding a lot I'll just
keep jabbing this in his face you just
do whatever you're gonna do he look out
oh ha ha ha can you can you cut his head
off let's put a smile on that face
chirping I don't know where we buy our
medical support it was sharp enough
sharp boy he no one cares is that your
good friend did you know we're operating
on Bob I didn't know that yeah said that
in the chart I read the chart before we
started oh I didn't read the chart yes
you need a sexier voice I'm a I'm a male
nurse no I don't care if you're a male
nurse you need a sexy voice that male
nurses kind of sexy voices don't that's
not good enough
[Music]
well maybe that's because I am we have a
very strange relationship in this
operating yes get in there get down and
dirty with light just get in there dig
in dig in all feast and we're here to
enjoy this doesn't seem I don't care
what you think no this is how I operate
we're not here to save the pace of words
when I got my nursing certificate from
ITT Tech this was not should have
government from DeVry that's where I
learned how to medical school nurse I do
love their commercials they are good
with did you notice when I was in there
no I didn't because I wasn't it was drip
duty his father apparently that was such
a point was like
there was almost no reason for me to lie
about that it's almost like okay would
you ever mentally in Spain
no it can't be true I'm sure I can't
even tell which arms mine there's so
much blood going on I guess I'm the
right arm still you're yes you never
change wouldn't this be more effective
if we both use both of them no no no no
do we know he's dying no no these are
nurse yes that's all the time we got
because literally bob has to get on a
plane yes they op in a car and get on a
plane in like an hour
put some pants on should put some pants
on so we got to go right now so thank
you all so much for watching thank you
for enjoying this we'll play this again
maybe maybe I'll play it with wait cuz I
have more time with a mean leave later
alright thank you all so much for
watching check out Bob's channel in the
description below he's hilarious and all
that stuff but you probably heard before
but check them out anyway wait and get
the [ __ ] out of here as always we'll see
you in the next video bye
[Music]
[Laughter]